en france un enfant sur trois ne partira
pas en vacances cette année un chiffre
connaît bien le secours populaire depuis
ils se mobilisent pour leur offrir deux
mini séjour alors aujourd'hui près de
5000 petits franciliens sont partis à
ouistreham en normandie un bol d'air
mais aussi une leçon d'histoire valérie
fournis ou cécile michard le parcours
s'annonce studieux pour ces petits
déshérités de la région parisienne
plus de 4000 enfants encadrés par le
secours populaire qui débute cette
journée à la mer par le mémorial de caen
et là les gars on salue la bravoure des
soldats américains
la france
la france il n'y avait pas que les
américains si l etat malien et les
anglais ils ont entre 6 et 12 ans et
déjà conscients de leur chance de n'être
pas né dans ces années sombres
cette guerre qui les effraie et les
étonne ses grands dont ils ne
comprennent pas toujours les actes
mais peu importe aujourd'hui c'est la
fête la mer la baignade tant attendue
est la leçon d'histoire du matin oubliez
sans complexe mais il ne sait bien qu à
ouistreham ce sont les français qui ont
débarqué en juin 44
quant aux modalités volet lequel nous
nous envolons quasiment s'il y avait les
allemands dedans pourquoi
qui se passait chez son dauphin
seulement
si tous n'ont pas comme elle retenu la
leçon du jour
l'important est que ces oubliés des
vacances et eu la chance même une
journée de prendre le large
loin de leur site